en 1989 patrick dils fut condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité pour
le meurtre de deux enfants de 8 ans
commis à montigny lès metz en moselle
un comité de soutien de patrick dils bat
pour faire reconnaître son innocence et
de l'avocat patrick dils m florent a
innové en organisant une reconstitution
privée cet après-midi sur les lieux du
crime
car pour lui l'instruction a été bâclée
reportage valérie ermite et thierry
breton c'est un rendez-vous singulier
pour une reconstitution hors du commun m
florent l'avocat de patrick dils a
convoqué la presse pour une
reconstitution privée
une reconstitution cents magistrats sont
prévenus sans contradicteur et sans
aucun cadre juridique mais l'important
pour eux et ailleurs démontré les
contradictions du dossier
les corps des deux enfants était relevé
approximativement dans ce périmètre la
la c'est à dire à plus de 40 mètres de
l'endroit où patrice va situer les deux
crémât schémas à l'appui
le comité de soutien de patrick dils
approuve sept ans qu'ils à fond ces
voies de chemin de fer et plonge dans ce
dossier à la recherche de la moindre
incohérence la 4cv de patrick et les
captv situe donc le décès de patrick
l'institut dvd le décès des enfants
à aucun moment il ne le situe là où la
lieux a eu lieu les crimes à aucun
moment au maire stragier est un policier
à la retraite il était là le jour de la
véritable reconstitution et se dit
aujourd'hui lui aussi convaincu de
l'innocence de patrick
imaginez si ça pouvait être mon fils
qu'il soit en prison et que quelqu'un
sache de détails comme ça qui se rajoute
à d'autres qui font une certitude
finalement ne disent rien une démarche
hors normes dans un dossier qui l'est
tout autant
en juin dernier fait rarissime la cour
de révision a ordonné un supplément
d'enquêté
car la présence de francis heaulme tueur
en série sur les lieux du crime est
maintenant avérée pour l'avocat de
patrick dils
il s'agit aujourd'hui d'accélérer le
cours de la justice
on a du mal à comprendre que la cour de
révision prenne tout son temps dans un
dossier qui devrait être prioritaire
puisqu'il s'agit certainement de la plus
monstrueuse erreur judiciaire que la
france ait connu
une reconstitution sans aucune valeur
juridique au risque d'agacer les
maristes
en charge de l'enquêté un risque que
l'avocat dit préférer à celui du
maintien d'un éventuel innocents en
prison